การประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัมเข้าสู่ยุคแห่งประโยชน์ใช้งาน
หมายความว่าเราเริ่มนำคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมมาใช้แก้ปัญหา
ในโลกความเป็นจริง รวมถึงปัญหาบางอย่างที่ยากมาก
สำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
รูปแบบที่พบบ่อยในยุคปัจจุบัน
คือปัญหาหนึ่งได้รับการแก้
เป็นครั้งแรกบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
แล้วต่อมาผู้คนก็หาวิธีทำมันบนคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
วงจรนี้ของการประมวลผลแบบคลาสสิก
และควอนตัมที่ผลักดันซึ่งกันและกันไปสู่
ขีดจำกัดของมัน น่าจะดำเนินต่อไป
อีกสักไม่กี่ปี มีประเภทของปัญหาที่ควอนตัม
คอมพิวติ้งสามารถมีข้อได้เปรียบที่พิสูจน์ได้
เหนือการประมวลผลแบบคลาสสิก
เมื่อมีความก้าวหน้าในด้านต่างๆ เช่น
การลดข้อผิดพลาดและจำนวน qubit ที่มีอยู่
ยังมีพื้นที่การประยุกต์ใช้ทั้งหมด
ที่การประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัม
อาจมีประโยชน์ในระยะเวลาอันใกล้
หนึ่งในนั้นคือ quantum machine learning หรือ QML
quantum machine learning หมายถึง
การนำการประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัมมาใช้กับกระบวนการ machine learning
ทุกประเภท แน่นอนว่ามี
machine learning หลายประเภท
สองประเภทที่น่าสนใจเป็นพิเศษคือ
supervised learning ที่คุณ
เทรน algorithm โดยใช้ชุดข้อมูลที่มี label
และ unsupervised learning ที่
algorithm ทำงานจากตัวอย่างที่ไม่มี label
และพยายามเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับการกระจาย
หรือฟังก์ชันที่สร้างมัน
algorithm แบบ unsupervised อาจ
เรียนรู้วิธีสร้างตัวอย่างใหม่
จากการกระจายเดียวกัน หรือวิธีที่จะ
จัดกลุ่มตัวอย่างตามลักษณะที่คล้ายกัน
ทั้ง supervised และ unsupervised learning มักเกี่ยวข้องกับ
การ embed ข้อมูลในพื้นที่หลายมิติ
และการจัดการข้อมูลในพื้นที่หลายมิติ
ควรทำให้เรานึกถึงการประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัม
ขอให้ฉันอธิบาย ลองนึกภาพการแก้ปัญหาว่าจะ
จำแนกจุดข้อมูลบนระนาบ
ว่าเป็นวงกลมหรือกากบาท จากข้อมูลเทรนที่มี label ตรงนี้
บางครั้งข้อมูลสามารถแบ่งแยกได้ชัดเจนด้วยเส้น
หรือระนาบในมิติต่ำ
ดังที่แสดงไว้ที่นี่ และการจำแนกจุดข้อมูลเหล่านี้ตาม
ที่อยู่เหนือเส้น
และใต้เส้น น่าจะ
ไม่มีปัญหา แต่ดูที่การกระจายนี้
ชัดเจนว่าไม่มีเส้นที่มองเห็นได้ซึ่งแบ่งแยกจุดข้อมูล
แต่สำหรับข้อมูลนี้ เราอาจนึกภาพ
การ mapping จากสองมิติไปสามมิติ
ซึ่งหลังจากใช้ mapping แล้ว ข้อมูลของเราจะดู
แบบนี้ และมีระนาบที่แบ่งแยกสอง class ชัดเจน ซึ่งเราสามารถใช้
สำหรับการจำแนก ถ้าการอธิบายนี้ดูง่ายเกินไป
คุณพูดถูก เราไม่สามารถแค่เอาจุดข้อมูลที่ต้องการ
ขึ้นไปไว้ด้านบนโดยไม่มีเหตุผลรองรับ
ต้องมี mapping
จากการกระจายสองมิติที่แบ่งแยก
จุดข้อมูลของเราได้จริง เพื่อที่เราจะ
ใช้ mapping นั้นจำแนกจุดข้อมูลใหม่ได้
เรื่องนี้จะพูดถึงมากขึ้นในบทเรียนที่ให้
สรุป machine learning แต่พอจะบอกได้ว่า
ปัญหานี้มองได้ว่า
เป็นการลอง mapping ต่างๆ มากมายไปสู่พื้นที่หลายมิตินี้
เพื่อดูว่า mapping ใดให้การแบ่งแยกที่ดีที่สุด
ของจุดข้อมูลต่าง class กัน
การจัดการข้อมูลในมิติสูงนี้
เป็นพื้นที่หนึ่งที่การประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัม
อาจมีผลกระทบสูง เพื่อเข้าใจว่าทำไม
กลับมาดูความแตกต่างระหว่างคลาสสิก
และการประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัม เช่นเดียวกับที่
คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกใช้บิตของข้อมูล
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมใช้ qubit
แต่สำหรับจำนวนบิตที่กำหนด สมมติสี่บิต
คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกสามารถอยู่ในสถานะใดก็ได้จาก
สองยกกำลังสี่ หรือสิบหกสถานะที่เป็นไปได้
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมก็เข้าถึงสิบหกสถานะที่เป็นไปได้ได้เช่นกัน
แต่มันสามารถอยู่ใน superposition ของทุก
สิบหกสถานะพร้อมกัน
และสามารถดำเนินการกับ superposition ทั้งหมดนี้ได้
สำหรับสี่ qubit นี้อาจดูไม่
ใหญ่โตอะไรมาก แต่ลองนึกภาพว่าจะทำอะไรได้บ้างกับ
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมใน สองยกกำลังยี่สิบ หรือ
สองยกกำลังหนึ่งร้อยยี่สิบเจ็ด
สถานะพร้อมกัน ยังมีความแตกต่างอื่นๆ อีกมาก
ระหว่างการประมวลผลแบบคลาสสิกและควอนตัม ที่จะ
มีบทบาทในเรื่องนี้ทั้งหมด
สถานะควอนตัมมีค่า amplitude ความน่าจะเป็นแบบจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
การจัดการระบบควอนตัมดำเนินการด้วย
ตัวดำเนินการ unitary และคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอยู่ภายใต้ noise
ประเภทต่างๆ จากคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
ความแตกต่างเหล่านี้จะปรากฏ
ตลอดงาน quantum machine learning ของคุณในด้าน
การ encode ข้อมูล feature mapping และการลด error
ในบางกรณี ความแตกต่างระหว่างคลาสสิก
และคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมช่วยให้เราออกแบบ
algorithm ใหม่ทั้งหมดได้ นั่นเป็นภาพรวมสั้นๆ มาก
ของการรวมกันของสองสาขาที่ซับซ้อนอย่างมาก
แต่หวังว่าสองสิ่งจะชัดเจน
machine learning มักแก้ปัญหา
ด้วยการจัดการข้อมูลในมิติสูงมาก
และประการที่สอง คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเหมาะมาก
สำหรับการจัดการข้อมูลในมิติสูง
และทำได้ต่างจากระบบคลาสสิก
นี่น่าจะทำให้คุณเห็นภาพ
ว่าทำไม machine learning จึงเป็นสาขาที่มีแนวโน้มดี
สำหรับการประยุกต์ใช้การประมวลผลเชิงควอนตัมที่เป็นประโยชน์